seth as i hold my news mug there is a
budding young journalist from idaho
falls who
became an internet sensation for her
interviews with so many people of note
and she's just seven years old
and she's already been on the show once
she is back
and she's gonna interview us if that's
cool
i'm so excited all right please welcome
back to the show
emmy eaton
[Applause]
thanks so much for having me back
oh my goodness thank you so much for
coming
back and taking a crack at interviewing
myself and seth so we are your subjects
you are conducting the interview we're
so happy to be
in the seats um with you uh take it away
i'm a little nervous because i hear you
ask the hard questions
seth how did you get your start in show
business
well i was doing a two-person show
in chicago illinois with my comedy
partner at the time
and i was lucky enough that someone from
saturday night live
was in the audience that night and that
basically started the process where i
ended up with my first job
on tv which was here on snl
drew what's your favorite ice cream
flavor
you know it's mint chip and whenever
it is and guess what i mean when i was
pregnant with my two daughters it i was
like
i just all i ate was mint chip set
my answer is zach ron and justin bieber
who's yours
my dream interview would probably be
beyonce i was gonna say the same thing
seth
well uh you didn't and it's too late
what's your favorite things to do with
olive and frankie
one thing that we do every single night
without fail is we watch
old school cartoons and that's a good
ritual that we have
seth is it really hard to make people
laugh every day
good question only my wife most other
people i do a pretty good job with but
uh
it's tough sometimes okay seth andrew
can you make me laugh right now
i will only say this uh drew told me
you were cute and i am incredibly
disappointed to find out that you were
in fact
very cute and i should have been warned
that got a laugh um i'm gonna
tell you guys a joke but it's kind of
inappropriate
oh bring it on emmy why did the toilet
paper not cross the road
because of the crack
[Applause]
well that's like just like an anatomy
joke that's basically science
i feel like your boys would like that
joke seth
they probably they sadly would um i know
my daughters are gonna love that joke
i'm gonna tell it to them
this afternoon um i can't think
of more amazing company that i might be
able to be in
right now than with you emmy and with
you seth
thank you guys so much thank you for
having me so nice to meet you emmy
i learned a lot of tricks from you today
[Applause]
thank you bye
please check out late night with seth
meyers weeknights at 12
35 on nbc just got picked up for five
more years so i think that says it all
congratulations bye drew thank you
[Music]